companies are not about any one person  right it's really not about any two  people either they're these combinations  of of people and teams and  i think the ones that that work best are  when you have people who have different  strengths who complement each other and  i think a huge part of the success of  facebook and our ability to grow the  community has been because of the  partnership that we've built and um and  a number of other really special people  here who are on the the core group who  just each have different skills and are  very different and are not afraid to to  challenge each other and  bring their voice to the table and  i think that's a special thing